[Music]
there's a
a british man brett ash
i just said jamaican style
yeah what was with that i said mon yeah
mon
there are a lot of there are a lot of
jamaicans in britain
true yeah like a pokemon so i was just
from that district it's going to be
inclusive kingston town here we go so
a british mon uh is at risk of facing
the death penalty oh in iraq after being
accused of attempting to smuggle
historic artifacts oh he shouldn't be
trying to steal [ __ ] from samaria then
but was he though let me give you the
don't [ __ ] with mesopotamia dawg that's
ancient babylon
dude joe just watched a 15-minute
documentary on youtube last night
while he was pooping he was watching
during his 15-minute [ __ ] he was like
well that's pretty amazing short [ __ ]
yeah okay load up your vocab mesopotamia
ancient babylon
samaria insert it later
so a retired geologist named jim fitton
age 66 has been detained in iraq on
allegations of smuggling after he
visited the country for a geology and
archaeology tool but he's retired he has
retired yes i know that's already
conflicting just one last job guys that
one last job
so in terms of the smuggling what had
happened was
whilst on tour our this is their family
reaching out to the uk uh government in
order to act on this help by helping me
help us yeah exactly
hey we need help
[Laughter]
i can't tell if he's from texas or the
uk god do a little bit more what else
what do you say
on the phone we just need help help me
say garth brooks he just keeps trying
to help me okay he's liverpool
well didn't mean to steal them
they said whilst on tour our father
visited historical sites around iraq
where his tour group found fragments of
stones and shards of broken pottery and
piles on the ground why what's with
pottery we do we really like the pottery
so much
that's always pottery we have enough
pottery
that's it you like all that kind of [ __ ]
who took a [ __ ] pot of shards
broken isn't geology rocks
isn't that what that is it is
why is he picking up pottery for maybe
that's his hobby because they rock i
think he's having an identity crisis
all
yeah
so uh they said these fragments were in
the open unguarded and with no signage
warning against removal tour leaders
also collected the shards as souvenirs
at the site in eridu he's like they did
it too [ __ ]
members were told that this would not be
an issue as the broken shards had no
economic or historic value oh okay
not historically though why are they
[ __ ] taking clay tablets and [ __ ] and
it said that we think that our father
may be put on trial the week commencing
may 8th which is in three days from this
moment i don't know
uh in iraq we have days to save him
before sentencing and we need the
foreign office to help by intervening in
this case well by the time this video is
up we can't [ __ ] help because we post
[ __ ] way late
this guy's probably dead already
[ __ ] yeah
well they'll follow we're trying to do
the right thing are they gonna kill them
there's there's the death sentence
possibility for [ __ ] pottery [ __ ]
damn bro i'll [ __ ] bake you some new
[ __ ] ceramics chill man
remember there's a difference between
smuggling pottery versus ancient
artifacts
what they need to do when you go into a
new country actually find some ancient
ones outside
and it's the stupid tour guide he was
like no problemo you guys want to take
some clay tablets go ahead because you
won't get killed before
i first went to hawaii i'm like oh man i
love this place so much and i was like
grabbing up some seashells and some
rocks and stuff
i'm gonna take it back and then someone
told me no no that's bad luck you don't
do that here i'm like oh i didn't know
that so i left put it all down but if
that was at the airport i wouldn't even
have put that in my pocket in the first
place
that it was bad luck
yeah they said you [ __ ] to get
haunted or some [ __ ] they do say that
they said they duty free story in hawaii
oh that's the lava rocks oh yeah right
in the sand you're not supposed to take
the sand that's the petrified wood
oh really see just don't take stuff from
hawaii beaches that's what they told me
no more and i listened i took a leaf
they should take some rocks out of
hawaii beaches actually that'd be pretty
nice they could take all the rocks but
leave the sand because it's nice and
soft
dang i haven't been to hawaii in like 20
years 20 years probably you should
definitely come down during the summer
when i open up junebe in waikiki
just don't go in the water i'll i'll
handle it for you if you want to feel
like what it's like you just go like
[ __ ] hawaii the rocks
are talking about the corals or what are
you talking about the rocky ass beaches
do you ever go to waikiki it's like all
[ __ ] up you're at the rock beach
tell me about it tell me about it
there's a lot of sandy beaches too
where at the resorts
yeah that's where i want to go hey hey
drop me a link
send me your itinerary i see a lot of
howie's though i don't know well this
might be one of those like shittier
situations where it's like maybe like
upon landing at the airport just like
all the rules but then when you actually
go to the sites there's like no signage
or anything like that you know what i
mean but
apparently under quote unquote uh
article 41 of the iraqi artifacts law
number 55 of 2002 the offense uh now
sees said father-in-law facing a
potential death sentence and what
happened to the the other people are
they is it so trying to leave it was
just him and another german person who
was on the tour that ended up getting uh
stopped what about other people on a
tour yeah who's snitching tour guide
they were like it's fine grab whatever
you want watch some [ __ ] yeah yeah
german in the brick get em get em get em
that's crazy can't they do community
service or some [ __ ]
god damn different [ __ ] pottery dude
i think i think community service is a
fair punishment yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] scrub some floors or something
or like i don't know or make more
pottery this is americans react to iraqi
laws
wow what the [ __ ] just have them like
ride a bike to make energy or something
i love your american library or
something for a couple weeks
can't they just pick up trash like
everybody else yeah and they fight
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
there's clothes all over the floor
because i'm an american boy you went
straight to the size of you i was just
like ethan allen or something
i used it earlier
safe space that's a sacred place
that's [ __ ] crazy dude it'd be funny
you're gonna die over [ __ ]
picking up clay how funny if they did
sentence him to pick up trash it's okay
you can just go pick up trash and he
finds actual artifacts
and he's like [ __ ] man
what do you do get sentenced for
throwing away actual artifacts
no he gets sentenced for putting trash
in the museum
god damn i
so what do you think the odds are of
like them actually going to trial and
just going okay on closer inspection
this is just garbage you're fine do you
think that would happen
is it really this serious i mean if it's
in the law like well as a supporter of
cruel and unusual punishment here we go
i feel like
in this case
it does feel a little bit out of bounds
because i i cuz usually
because we gotta send them this video
intention is the key
like if you're a thief and you stole gum
your hands should be cut off that's fine
because your intention was to steal okay
but if you grab the piece of gum and
you're in a deep conversation and you
accidentally put it in your pocket just
because uh you're just a weird human a
habit and then you walk out of the store
and you go
oh [ __ ] i stole and then right away
there's iraqi police freeze you son of
[ __ ] you know then they [ __ ] get you
and then they're like
it's not what it looks like because i've
done that before i stole chocolate from
food land in hawaii
i'll say right now i have no [ __ ]
shame i should have my dick cut off for
that but i did it by accident wait why
are your dick cut off it doesn't make
really sense is that what you used to
steal it let him talk he said it he said
it he's going to just in case he gets
caught we want to make sure it's on two
hands he he caught he stole it with his
dick yeah oh there it is
he didn't knock it off
on accident he was like talking over
here and he was like yeah
his urethra was like
oh you could suck with yours
yeah my she's like the clap
it's like
what is it the elephant trunk
i am uncircumcised so it does that
i'm only here sucks
you my god it knocked off the chocolate
no i just pictured it yeah i picked it
up and i was like oh chocolate and then
i was talking to david what should we
get should we get cake or something and
i put it in my pocket and i left and
then we got to the house and i'm like
oh my god i shoplifted i'm going to get
my dick cut off
that's what you did with his arms she
was like go ahead i forgave myself
because it was accident it was intention
did you eat it yeah
[Laughter]
he's always like this guy should have
the same thing happen to him
and then joe's like i forgive myself for
this crime and i will eat this product
that i stole
but you know what i did to makeup
you know uh well i was thinking about
going back and paying for it but then i
didn't want to admit to a crime so what
i ended up doing was buying very
expensive pineapple and i'm like all
right that margin should should work for
me
from the same place in the same area
return to the scene of the crime free
june before hawaiian residency
[Music]
you